36 this morning Super Bowl weekend well
if you didn't know it's this weekend so
have you placed your bet well in Las
Vegas of course we're used to sports
wage dream but gradually it's becoming
more common in popular Nationwide
Candace Charles is live in The Newsroom
this morning with more on where you can
put your money where your mouth is
Candace good morning well online is the
most obvious one we've been hearing
about but now there are 33 States in
Washington D.C and the record 50.4
million Americans are expected to bet on
this year's Super Bowl that's according
to the American gaming Association who
also says 30 million Americans plan to
place traditional Sports Wagers online
at Rito's sportsbooks or with a bookie
unlv's International gaming Institute
says most of the betting will likely
still happen here and a lot of people
will actually still come here for the
Super Bowl to place those bets but they
also say other states are very much
growing at their legal sports betting
New York and New Jersey beat us last
year as the top spending state but
unlike anywhere else Vegas has something
special
even though you know now say in New York
or in Washington DC you can pull out
your phone and place a bet on the Super
Bowl this is still a place where people
love to come and place their bet on the
big game here and then spend the whole
weekend having an amazing experience and
there is a lot to do now so far
California will be our biggest
competitor but for now sports betting is
not happening there now better's plan to
wager an estimated 16 billion on this
year's big game the most common novelty
bet is the coin toss result in Caesar
sports book right here in Vegas appears
to have the best odds of any major
betting platform for now in The Newsroom
I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now